[Laughter]
and that's where we come in massacre
that's right a Japanese anime dubbed by
Americans analyzed by two Peretz it
makes a massive coax from Dragon Ball Z
abridge and little kuriboh from yugioh
abridged that's right two Brits Bach
okay um I don't know a ton about the
enemy but that really doesn't look like
a Goku well as a white man I'm offended
to the line like that is inherent
British bluster
Wow I really didn't think this with the
angle you guys would lean of course of
course
[Laughter]
that's where it never happens not to
follow these I'm just aiming this at my
crotch that's not smart
we don't want to put any effort into
Japan's Japan screw those guys
oh and who could forget I could don't
forget you get stock additional no don't
forget you get stock additional sorry
this is stock additional what stock
parental advice for no additional
starter a rental vice promoters
apocalyptic utopian techno my favorite
genre of music
it is awesome
this is that shit we got a cut two horny
Goku Goku but it looks like Goku's help
with the lockers my tavern Dunson tale
not actual tale bed be like the show by
catching sometimes we do he'd be doing
into himself
yeah freak with you good looks in yeah
nice clothes in yeah yeah wah dressed it
up or a nice half ounce of clothes okay
alright yeah you freak with you yeah
yeah you're good clothes in yeah nice
hair and yeah I fucked it up again
nevertheless he defeats the bullies and
gets friendly with chichi horny Goku
morning Goku rides again
mommy Goku rides again Oh sister sister
then they get that at Britain we're
mourning the loss of our favorite rice
braces they agree to join forces to find
the other dragonballs and they ride on
her and they ride on her like you're d
goku let me try
I'd be so grateful if you would help me
and my friends up
very different the Valentine's Day
episode yeah let me try
I'd be so grateful if you would just
help me and my friends out we should
just live here okay you don't yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah
no it's always bringing down earth-boy
Ghostbuster jokes
well I swear that happens to all guys
not me you're different I like you
you're special let's ride our homes
[Laughter]
hashtag popular phrase and still more
excited
hashtag popular phrase not until you say
it like a gift not like a give it like a
given that B when we're entertaining a
minute and a half what the hell can you
show in that amount of time
well the suspenseful picking of the what
build-up of picking plans
[Laughter]
stop No - stop don't be a douche come on
sorry oh no he's turned into 3d pipes
really laughing on that one
[Music]
oh no he's turned into 3d pipes is very
fine okay giggles oh okay oh no he's
turned into 3d pipes
[Laughter]
oh no he's turned into 3d pipe okay oh
no he's turned into 3d pipes
oh no he's turned into 3d pipes
[Laughter]
oh my god I'm so sorry this is good this
is so professional
okay all right Jamie you talk shame okay
whenever you're ready oh no he's turned
into 3d pipes one more for safety -
gasps oh no he's turned into 3d pipes
man I don't know what it was about that
line that was just like
you